it's not fun Nicole Mike singer Denver
Post um
they're after the Lakers series you were
asked you know who are you most happy
for who you most excited for and you
said Jamal
um now that you guys are NBA champions
and you kind of look around the locker
room and look at your teammates who are
you most happy for all of them you know
I think it's simple it's all of them you
know I'm happy for DJ I'm happy for Jeff
I'm happy for ish
literally for everybody Mikey
he had three surgeries and still came
here and helped help us win the
championship
I'm burping I'm sorry
Jamal who who had a surgery and didn't
play well at the beginning of the Season
like I told you guys that he is not
going to build but we all know what he's
capable of
so it's every kcp you know he Brothers
the championship mentality Bruce uh
Christian Brown I don't want to sit like
little every player every player on this
team
Melissa on the front Melissa Roland Fox
Sports Nicola 41st pick in the draft
it's been an incredible journey for you
to get to this moment how would you
describe the emotions of this all
it's good I mean it's good oh we did a
job we did a job
uh
I think we played the best basketball uh
I'm on the senior in a in a post season
but I think we were there uh playing the
best about playing the best basketball
you know today we didn't make shots but
still we'd defend and uh
I think it's it's uh it's a it's a great
journey like you said uh for the first
for the first pick but to be honest that
doesn't matter when you hear you're a
player and they have couple guys that uh
not even drafted and they're still
playing and contributing to them to win
so
home over here let's finish good job
ESPN you've often talked about how you
don't care about MVPs you care about a
championship what is this Championship
mean for you compared to the NBC and
finals MVP and when you look at the
future what is this capable of
propelling you guys because I think you
have the starting five lockdown for
maybe the next couple years
I didn't know that that's great uh but
to be honest I don't think about the
next year I'm gonna ask the coach to to
game a couple weeks a couple weeks more
off uh so I can I can be ready for the
season uh
that's supposed to be a joke and you
didn't laugh
good job guys
um yes but you know
we have to have we have a we have a
but it's not the starting unit guys for
real it's it's the whole team uh like I
said this is day one in San Diego it was
something different about this team I
felt it uh I felted something some
different different energy and every day
since since the day it was I had the
same feeling so uh I'm not really
optimistic guy but uh
that that gave me a hope that we can do
something we can do something
third row on your right and you call it
we go ask and Turkish television
congratulations on winning the
championship
um
European basketball so much success in
the NBA uh you're one of the best
players to come out of Europe can you
talk about what Europe's impact is in
the NBA right now yes yes we have we
have a we have a we have an impact on
things but of course Americans are are
the majority of of the league and
they're supposed to be because they're
you know the America USA one I don't
know how many gold medals in a row and
then Spain won it last year's but but I
think there is some European players and
there will be some European players
contributing to win in uh and giving
that edge or
to the good teams to win the win
championship
Ramona on the left side the middle hi
Nicola ESPN you know coach has talked a
lot about part of the reason this group
is here is because the organization was
patient that that you guys have all been
together for quite a while and that the
you kind of were patient through the
injuries and through the the last couple
of years but but even stretching further
back how important was that and how how
important is that for a player to know
that the organization believes in the
core and believes in the group that
you've had for quite a while
uh yes I mean especially if you're a
young player you know I came here when I
was 20. Jamal was he came here and he is
20.
1 or 20. where is uh I don't know nobody
I'm by myself
sorry sorry uh yes but uh
yes the core but then I think you'd you
need if you want to be a successful you
need couple years you need to you need
to be a bad then you need to be the good
and then you need to figure then you
need to when you're good you need to
fail
and then when you fail you're gonna
figure it out you know I think the
experience is something that is not what
happened to you is what you're gonna do
with that would happen what happened to
you know and uh yes Jamal was injured
yes we lose the first round or second
round in the play if I don't even
remember who even who remembers but
there is a process that you need to you
need to
there is a steps that you need to fill
and it's it's a it's not uh it's not
there is no shortcuts there it's uh it's
it's a it's a journey and uh I'm glad
that I'm part of this journey
front right
you're drunk
Nicola Tara McKee 1043 The Fan
um you said after the Lakers when you
said you were surprised that you didn't
feel more so I'm curious what you are
feeling right now and if you're looking
forward to a parade coming up in Denver
minutes parade
Wednesday Thursday
no
I need to go home okay
uh
I mean it's a it's a
I mean this is actually this succeed in
our jobs and we we wanted we want the
whole thing it's a it's a it's a amazing
feeling but like I said before it's not
everything on the wall you know I think
I think still if okay I want it okay not
I we want it but I think it's not the
most important thing in the world still
uh there is a bunch of things that uh
that I like that I like to do I mean
probably that's no that's a normal thing
you know nobody likes his uh his job or
maybe they do they're lying uh
but uh it's uh it's a good feeling when
you know that you did something that
nobody believes and just it was just us
it's just the organization of that nagas
believe in us uh every play We Believe
in each other and I think that's that's
the most important thing especially
up there on the stage with you yeah it's
not just you know my wife who who
who is with me since they won uh even in
Belgrade and my brothers that I live
with my brother actually we all live
together in one moment so it was a
circus but uh
you know there there are some bus some
somebody's that in my life means a lot
and without them I'm not gonna be here
Tim on the left fourth row Tim McMahon
ESPN uh Nicole there was a timeout in
the third quarter when you guys are down
and you know you're slamming the chairs
you're you're yelling over there what
were you so fired up about and how do
you feel like uh your teammates and you
guys responded after that
but I like how you make it bigger uh yes
I am I I yell at them because we were
just shooting trees and I think it was
like four and three we could just get a
easy layup and just score the ball I
think it's in that situation it means a
lot just to score a ball especially it's
a low scoring game we didn't make shots
they didn't make shots uh it was 90
something 80 80 something game uh I
think the easy points are something that
kills and uh
you know in that situation emotions yes
I held them but I think they're used to
it sometimes they yell at them sometimes
they cheer them so that's part of the
family and then part of the team
take last two Joe and then one in the
back Jovan the athletic you got kcp
pretty good up there I'm wondering if
anyone got you as as well in the locker
room
I don't remember but yes I think Sparky
got me
like but uh
it's a great emotions you know
everything is in the
in a good positive way
last one last one in the back in the
center
Nick from the jbk show Novak just won
the French Open you just won the finals
MVP and the championship is this the
greatest era of Serbian athletes
thank you
I'm going to be
a congratulations I'm gonna see the huge
Destiny no
I don't know I mean oh mama
how many texts you have a lot a lot I
know I'm not gonna I'm gonna turn off
the phone but uh yes I think it's a
you know sport is something that is
always in Serbia was something that put
us in front of everybody even like 10 20
years ago whatever uh but now when we
have a joke who want a probably the best
ever uh
for us he's the best ever of course and
uh now we have a now we have our MBO
championship and I think it's a it's a
really good uh good uh moment to be a
Serbian
thank you pleasure to call this guys